[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
listen to the read and the tailor tells
how it sings of separation ever since
they cut me off from the reed bed my
wail has caused men and women to weep I
want a heart that is torn open with
longing so that I might share the pain
of this love whoever has been parted
from its source longs to return to that
state of Union at every gathering I play
my lament and a friend to both happy and
sad
each befriended me for his own reasons
yet none searched out the secrets I
contained my secret is not different
than my lament that this is not for the
Census to perceive
the body is not hidden from the soul nor
is the soul hidden from the body and yet
the soul is not for everyone to see this
flute is played with fire and not with
wind and without this fire you would not
exist that is the fire of love that
inspires the flute
mr. ferment of love that completes the
wine
the read is a comfort to all estranged
lovers it's music tears our veils apart
have you ever seen a potion or antidote
like the read have you seen a more
intimate companion and lover
it sings of the path of blood it relates
the passion of Majnoon only to the
senseless is this sense confided does
they're telling you have any patrons of
the year our days grow more unseasonable
these days which mix with grief and pain
but if the days that remain are a few
let them go it doesn't matter but you
you remain for nothing is as pure as you
are all but the fish quickly have their
fill of his water and the day is long
without his daily bread
the raw do not understand the state of
the ripe and so my words will be brief
break your bonds be free my child
how long will silver and gold and slave
you if he pour the whole sea into a jug
would it hold more than one day store
[Music]
the greedy I like the jug is never
filled until content the oyster holds no
pearl only one who has been undressed by
love this free of defect and desire o
gladness soul of our partner and trade
healer of all our ills our Plato and
Galen remedy for our pride in our vanity
with love this earthly body could soar
in the air the mountain could arrive
some nimbly dance love gave life to
Mount Sinai o lover
Sinai was junk Moses lost consciousness
pressed to the lips of one in harmony
with myself I might also tell all that
can be told but without a common tongue
I am dumb even if I have a hundred songs
to sing
when the rose is gone in the garden
faded you will no longer hear the
nightingales song the beloved is all the
lovers just a veil the beloved is living
the lover a dead thing
if a love with holes it's strengthening
care the lover is left like a bird
without wings how will I be awake and
aware if the light of the beloved is
absent love wills that this word be
brought forth if you find the mirror of
the heart at all the rust has not been
cleared from its face o friends listen
to this tale the marrow of our inward
state
[Music]